hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the Resident Evil 2 remake finally
showed its face at e3 with a small
section playable to attendees the
nostalgia came flooding back so I
couldn't resist being up my ps1 and
revisiting the classic from 1998
comparing both versions of the title
it's possible to outline many ways the
Resident Evil 2 remake is far more than
a clone of its father
here's 9 ways the remake changes re 2 to
bring it kicking and zombie screaming
into the 21st century if you're watching
on your phone or tablet you may need to
up the brightness here as it gets hella
dark ok ready let's do this 20 years is
a damn long time in video games the
visual upgrades you see in the re to
remake take this game to the next level
they've achieved this by using the
Resident Evil 7 engine and applying it
to Resident Evil 2 and thanks to that
every room now looks petrifying and you
can almost smell the blood in every room
the visuals are so good that even the
characters mouths moved this time wow
that's that's progress speaking of
speaking another overhaul which needed
to be made was the voice acting here's
why I just found out John's dead what my
word that is terrible characters now
react in a way more akin to a real human
being for example this is Leon's first
day as a police officer back in 1998 he
approached the zombie apocalypse like it
happened every week
ADA ADA can you hear me
come on snap out of it whereas this time
Leon is indeed a rookie cop and is
constantly reassuring himself subtle
what definitely needed Jesus all this
adds to the survival horror element of
the game it's much harder to be a
confident player when the character
you're controlling
watch out
the iconic slow door open may be a thing
of beauty and suspense but 20 years
after resident evil 2 first released
current technology doesn't require the
same loading times as the original many
games hide loading screens in animation
too these days so don't expect to see
the slow door opening in each room just
run straight through that bad boy it'll
still be here though but only as a
callback to the 90s and to add a little
suspense the police station in re 2 was
the most ridiculous place in the world
from the statue in the foyer to the
pusher busts to unlock doors it was it
was silly but it was still great to get
round this drop in logic we were told
the police station was formerly an art
gallery and the puzzles were there as an
extra layer of security just in case
they were overrun by criminals come on
that does make it a little bit more
believable yeah ok so it's still
absolutely stupid but I loved it from
the 20 minute demo we know that the
station is generally the same as back in
1998 but with key changes to each of the
puzzles doors are locked in a different
way too for example the first door on
the left
has an electrical lock mechanism which
requires a knife to open just like in
Resident Evil 7 on the opposite side of
the station these electronic doors don't
work correctly so Leon has to commando
crawl underneath freaking petrifying
the bigger puzzles change in different
ways - such as the main statue but let's
not show you how that changes believe me
it's best to figure it out than to be
shown whilst making your way around the
station you'll bump into a zombie or two
or three off here you get the idea
these zombies are much more agile and
can't be avoided as gleefully as in 1998
back then we could skip hundreds of the
undead with a well-timed jog now well
now you'll be treated accordingly during
a bite the camera will move closer to
see the real terror and pain you're
going through back in the original when
you were bit by a zombie it looked like
you were getting a love bite you know
like when you were 14 you thought that
was cool it's not it's not you were
wrong not only other zombies a little
more aware of their surroundings they
are also capable of taking a bullet to
the face and surviving merely a step
back before they meander in your
direction again also not how gruesome
the shots to the face look knocking
chunks of flesh to the ground in
seemingly dynamic ways and once you put
them down they tend to get up again I'm
personally hoping the technique of
burning zombies as seen in re one remake
isn't brought in here spoiler alert for
re one if you killed a zombie and left
them downed you have to burn them to a
crisp or they would reanimate as a
zombie Usain Bolt and run your way like
those Z days gone either no thanks
maybe we need to keep that lighter handy
yeah
hmm sure you did what you could Leo
Marvin Brown Oh was the first character
Leon met in the police station back then
he was a consummate professional his
acting skills were top-notch such as
this general sorry but it looks like
your party has been canceled well Marvin
has been updated for the remake and
doesn't pull a gun on you immediately
this time now go but just go fine
instead Marvin isn't much more of a
hands-on member of your team yeah he's
gonna die soon judging by the bite on
his side but until that day comes he
sets up in the lobby and acts as a
mentor to Leon who remember is actually
a rookie cop this time around Marvin
will even save us early on so I think we
can trust
remember the corridor in resident evil 2
which saw a horde of zombie window
cleaners apatite well it's back in the
remake one of the best jump scares in
Resident Evil to happen when this
corridor you've run down a handful of
times previously does this as a child I
think I literally should my pants when
that happened guess what though it's
back in re to remake note to self
definitely wear the brown pants plain is
good his it changed the proceedings
though we now have the ability to bard
up a few windows around the police
station to prevent the zombies from
belly boarding in sight we're told that
resources will be scarce see what a
visitor so you'll need to decide which
windows are worth protecting and which
areas of the mansion you'll let overrun
and just avoid completely the combat
knife returns again in Resident Evil 2
remake it throws together all the uses
from previous installments if you'd like
to stand and flail like an idiot like
the good old days go for it
but durability has been added to knives
so with his breaks you'll need to find
another one
remember the remake of Resident Evil
which added daggers basically when
attacked by a zombie your character
would instantly take out a dagger and
embed it in the undead minion that has
made it over to the remake but with one
key difference stabbing a knife in a
zombie will embed the knife in their
chest or head so you'll have to get it
back somehow so if you start a fight
with a zombie finish it to get your
weapon back although differences are
important in a remake we still want some
of the best bits to remain untouched for
example Aeon meeting Claire before going
to the police station is confirmed by
this line in the demo yes I knew she'd
make it yeah
name's Claire I came into town with her
the director of the re 2 remake has also
confirmed that the fourth Survivor mode
will be present for those that don't
know the four survivor is a chap named
Punk who were sent into Raccoon City to
grab the g-virus for the umbrella
corporation his mode was essentially a
speed run minigame achieving a bunch of
a ranks would unlock a parody of this
mode called the tofu survivor which was
essentially identical to the four
survivor but instead a hardcore agent
was replaced with a lump of tow
which made the game a little more
difficult both modes have been confirmed
to be in the remaking and it won't be
DLC they'll be on the disc one last
little tidbit probably the most iconic
moment in Resident Evil 2 was the battle
with the oversized alligator I'm
delighted to say it's back in the remake
thanks to an interview between polygon
and the devs they have confirmed after
many redesigns the alligator did make it
to the remake before we finish let's
have a side-by-side comparison from 1998
all the way up to 2018 a lot has changed
in 20 years
[Music]
so there we go nine change is seen
between the 1998 and the 2019 version of
Resident Evil 2 from what we've seen of
the remake it both iterates upon the
original and pays homage throughout I
don't know about you but I'm super hyped
for this one any other re fans in the
house I'm Adam from PlayStation granade
I'm going to make a Jill sandwich I'll
see you next time it's been a pleasure